all right so the weekend is wrapping up
maybe you've seen glass hopefully you've
seen glass if you have it this is my
glass spoiler video there are spoilers
in here so don't want you to be haven't
seen glass or you care to see glass
there's time to shatter those
expectations all right in the reviews
out there
how many split unbreak shatter glass
references and puns did you have to put
up with a lot right I mean I did I
imagine more than a few reviews did it
that's what we're here for we came on
YouTube too one day
dude dad jokes and a final and very
important warning this video was filled
with my personal opinion and total
biases if you're expecting anything else
will allow me to shatter your
expectations possibly at the expense of
your enjoyment there at so here we go
and we'll start out on a positive note
the way this movie starts as David Dunn
is looking for the beast he's looking
for Kevin as kevin has some hostages and
so he's looking for him and that's
really yeah yeah that's exactly what
this movie would be at the end of split
I was like oh sweet he's going after him
and he did and it was great it was
amazing Danielle get captured there in
this facility where Sarah Paulsen's like
this is all in your head you're not
heroes what is there in this facility
and where I feel like a lot of people
have said this is when the movies boring
this is still good stuff in the movie
act 1 act 2 best parts of the movie I
like the facility I like the slow crawl
I even liked when you start seeing mr.
Glasco alright I'm figuring this out and
now I'm gonna start exacting my plan not
only does he pull one over on everybody
but their cells were so comic book right
the rooms are all staying and have that
thing that's essentially their weakness
and it's keeping them at bay nothing's
more comic book than that logical no but
for what this movie is I thought that
was neat there's this neat scene where
this guy is just flipping the switch
trying to have different personalities
come out of Kevin and that scene oh my
god James MacAvoy man robbed for the
Oscar for split or at least Oscar
nomination come on he had to have been
part of the conversation and David
Dunn's room has the sprinklers which I
feel like that is that a retcon I feel
like that's a wreck on the fact that
just touching water makes him weak the
way I understood it and I feel like I
just understood it incorrectly the way I
understood it and I'm breakable but
Elijah price sees that comic book about
superheroes who have weaknesses and he's
like aw crud is waters like his he even
says you're like me if you drink too
fast you choke you inhale water you
drown
water is like your kryptonite is just
kind of saying that you still need to
breathe like water can still drown you
it's his normal thing to think about but
Elijah price he he's insane and he sees
the world like comic books or maybe he's
the only sane one because he sees the
world like comic books point is that's
how he saw david dunn in water
breakable when he fell into the pool in
the tarp wrapped around him I just saw
it as like the tarp was wrapping around
him he couldn't get out he's gonna drown
he was probably scared out of his mind
sure but this movie glass takes it one
step further and now when he gets wet
he's just weak I didn't see it that way
and unbreakable I've actually had
conversations with people who saw it
that way no break balls like I don't
know we're just saying he drowns doesn't
make him weak or anything so either M
night Shyamalan retcon he'll water was
an unbreakable made it different in
class all right I was a couple people I
had that conversation with about water
and unbreakable and apology over I will
say this movie does touch on mental
makes physical like it doesn't quite hit
it home that does touch on the concept
of the brain's power over the body if
you believe something if your mind makes
it real it then physically manifest in
you they've already touched on that and
split that one doctor was like when
people when their brain chemistry
changes their body can do things in
other personalities they couldn't
otherwise the way it was presented I was
like I can buy that shirt in that fringe
way same with unbreakable but they'll
leap I had to take an unbreakable the
fact that he touches people and then he
can kind of just see flashes of the
things they've done wrong I was like all
right that's the mystical element there
but when Sarah Paulsen's talking to them
she's like no what you do is you're good
at deductive reasoning you're
essentially The Mentalist you size
people up and you know where they come
from what they've done immediately
you're like next level Sherlock I really
like that because I was like that
explains in a buyable way that you do
have to take half a leap but still
grounded in the realm of reality be it
maybe an exaggerated one it explains
that ability he has I really like that
until at the end she was like I was just
bullshitting you it's not real I was
[ __ ] with you did you think you were
normal goes like Oh does that undo that
conversation cuz I feel like that was a
really good description like there's a
really good basis as to how he could do
that so in that I can say that's what
the water thing is he had trauma when he
was a kid now he's definitely afraid of
water he believes water is his
kryptonite and that it would hurt him
ergo wouldn't he get splashed with water
he freaks out and he becomes weak kind
of like James McGill 's brother and
better call Saul not like electricity is
actually killing the guy from all fronts
if you have your cell phone around was
gonna melt his brain but he believes
that so his body physically reacts to
that I feel like that's what the whole
water thing is playing off of so I'm
thinking about it more I can buy that
and that's a really fascinating thing
it's a fascinating phenomenon study of
the brain's power over the body but this
movie never really hits at home so just
kind of disappoints me but I do have
questions about that wasn't always like
that can he drink water can he take
showers
badges you smell the end of this movie I
feel like this is what happens every
time Shyamalan wants to go back I mean
unbreakable and split the motivations in
there they're just very small personal
movies Elijah price wants to find his
opposite to find validation in his own
life which finding validation is
definitely his motivation in here but
it's all about execution it was less
interesting now at the end of
unbreakable he professes he sees David
Dunn as a friend even in glass he says
he's always seeing David Dunn as his
friend so while his motivation to prove
that heroes exist is in character forum
for him finding his validation in the
world which is essentially what people
want in the world I also feel like
something more personal between him and
David Dunn also would have been within
character I would have found that more
interesting because I'm more invested in
them and their dynamic as it stands
David Dunn in here is a tool a means to
an end same with the beast but I would
expect that with him in the base he
doesn't have that history David Dunn's
the one who first validated Elijah
prices presence at least in the eyes of
Elijah also Elijah price is the one who
turned David Dunn's world upside down
but also gave David Dunn purpose are you
taking a shot every time I say David
Dunn because you'd be dead now but it's
true but I wanted to see a more personal
story between those two I didn't really
get that here felt like Bruce Willis was
pushed to the side like he's charging by
the frame or something I just love this
movie disappointed expectations or no
and yes that definitely does have to do
with my own expectations call me a
traditionalist
I just think more interaction between
David Dunn and the mass murdering
terrorist who uprooted his life but also
gave more meaning to his life would have
had more paths after a nineteen-year way
but this would be also why is she in
this movie there's no reason for it
she's in this movie so she can touch the
Beast bring Kevin out so Kevin King gets
shot and killed because the Beast I
guess can survive bullets she shot him
and split he survived those she shot him
in the face he probably wouldn't walked
away from it but as it stands she didn't
shoot him in this movie some other guy
did from the court of clovers Hornet
making is you get a military sniper with
some high-velocity [ __ ] shoot the beasts
in the head or the heart he's not
walking away from that doesn't matter
who is or isn't touching him he's dead
so you don't need her and I just didn't
need the court of clovers to exist I
didn't need some super-secret shadow
organization that's been pulling the
strings from the beginning it's just
lazy to put something like that in a
movie like this it feels cheap it
creates loopholes like why weren't they
on David Dunn the moment they heard the
newscast that Elijah price heard the
moment there was a train crash that was
on the news and they heard there was a
train crash and miraculously there was
one survivor why
stay at his door just looking back those
shadow organizations you have to write
them well otherwise they minimize the
effect of what came before but I guess
we need them because now we need an
answer as to why there aren't more
heroes out there why is there just the
beast and the overseer I believe they
called me overseer or the tiptoe man but
now we have our answer this organization
convinces them they're full of [ __ ] or
they deceptive brains with a laser and
now we know in case you were asking but
I was never asking because the Liza
Price answered that and unbreakable
someone who doesn't get sick doesn't get
hurt like the rest of us and he probably
doesn't even know it
so that's why they probably don't even
know they have these abilities that is
the brilliance of unbreakable is
unbreakable caused us to look in
ourselves it's like what abilities do I
have no matter how seemingly small what
do I have that might be a little more
extraordinary than most other people
Usain Bolt's like I'm not a superhero
but sorry you [ __ ] are the flash is
an allegory for you man
so it's like that like what's the
difference between an Olympian and a
hero but hey this is the concluding
chapter of a trilogy so we gotta go
bigger
Elijah price is going to show people
that superheroes exist or at least two
really strong dudes and a guy with
osteogenesis imperfecta who's smart and
what we got was an end game that was
essentially the season four finale of
Heroes someone didn't want Claire to
show the world heroes exist and she did
now the words out there that locked away
like I've seen that before
I do enjoy the concept that with mr.
glass streaming the fight now the world
has that now it might change and alter
their perception and perspective to see
heroes where they wouldn't have seen
heroes before and shoot they might see
heroes where there are no heroes it
might just change society's perception
on everything as profound and reality
probably won't go that way it'll be a
viral video that'll catch on then people
move on to other [ __ ] I mean there are
videos on YouTube of like people walking
through [ __ ] and ghosts are real Google
or YouTube top ten most unexplained
phenomena caught on video
those aren't newsworthy it's not like
mainstream news outlets are running with
that so rally is probably be viral for
about a week and the world will forget
or will be passed off as a hoax with
actors or something sorry Elijah you
died for nothing and in the end nothing
changes the fact or nothing will change
the fact no matter how many times I
would choose to watch it to delve deeper
into the fabric of meaning contained in
the frames nothing would change the fact
that David Dunn still drowned and died
in a [ __ ] mud puddle because I'm
supposed to see it as some form of high
suck my [ __ ] dick David Dunn went out
like such a [ __ ] I hate it because you
imagine a Superman movie where Lex
Luthor gets like General Zod or doomsday
in fact Batman vs Superman you imagine
Batman vs Superman where Lex Luthor gets
the bruiser brawler to fight Superman
that would be doomsday in this case
Superman's not gonna die but in the end
some nameless faceless [ __ ] comes
over from the court of clovers with a
tattoo and just holds Superman's head
and a little mud puddle until he drowns
to death you telling me you wouldn't
scream [ __ ] you to the screen I would
you can really take anything if someone
held Jack Bauer's head in a mud puddle
that would suck to Walter White drown
him in a mud puddle that'd be stupid
take your protagonist if they just
drowned in a mud puddle by jackoff Joe
Blow nobody that was first introduced in
the frame in the scene the shot that
drowned the person that would be dumb
and it was dumb here granted on one hand
I recognize that showing how easily
someone who's that strong could go out
could be a profound moment but the
payoff with that moments forged in the
story arc at hand it's how you treat the
character here where he came from his
legacy his arc I just didn't feel the
payoff here I felt like this was
Shyamalan trying to have his Coen
brothers moment and I just don't feel it
worked those are my thoughts
agree or disagree that's how I feel it
really was the end I would have been
fine with the movie if he just stuck the
landing of the end I just feel like
bringing in a super-secret organization
was lazy in fact he got the message out
doesn't mean anything to me if this came
out in the early 2000s that would be
profound as it stands now that's it's
not no one's gonna care I don't need
something grand like I said just
personal I don't need something big like
they did the big ending essentially they
might just change the world the people
on the internet don't forget about it in
a week but that's less fulfilling than a
movie that really revolved more around
David Dunn and mr. glass undeniably just
with human beings people if an ending
falls flat feels awkward or unfulfilled
it just leaves you there feeling like
huh